attorney general bill Barr speaks out
against president from Twitter logorrhea
Trump goes after former chief of staff
John Kelly and Joe Biden turns on
Michael Bloomberg I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn surf the
web with peace of mind signed up now at
expressvpn dot-com slash been already so
the big story of the day is that
President Trump now apparently sort of
kind of at odds with his attorney
general bill Barr why because bill Barr
finally had the temerity to tell Trump
shut up I mean that's basically what
happened here President Trump has an
unfortunate habit unfortunate habit is
he feels the need to sound off on every
single topic ever now if you were doing
the podcast or if you were doing a radio
show or even if you were just a
commenter on Daily wire this would all
make perfect sense the problem is he's
the President of the United States and
when he sounds off it sounds as though
he has utilized his authority to
effectuate the things that he is
sounding off about so the example that
we must use is of course the case of
Roger stone so CNN reported just a
couple of days ago that all four federal
prosecutors who took the case against a
longtime Donald Trump confidant Roger
stone to trial withdrew on Tuesday after
tough Justice Department officials
undercut them and disavowed the
government's recommended sentence
against stone you'll remember that Roger
stone during the campaign was acting as
sort of a go-between for various sources
who claimed access to WikiLeaks and then
he kept trying to funnel information to
trump and it was pretty clear that that
trump wasn't to actively coordinating
with stone to actually go after Hillary
Clinton's emails with with the with
WikiLeaks or anything like that but
stone was a basically actor he kept
trying to act at this go-between he kept
trying to get information from WikiLeaks
and pass it on to Trump and trauma be
like that's nice Roger and then Roger
stone would go and tell witnesses to
shut up I mean that that's what the
evidence it seems to show so he is
convicted of lying to Congress and he is
convicted of a couple of other crimes
and he is given a recommended sentence
by Justice Department lawyers of up to
nine years and this was considered way
too much by the Attorney General and by
the top of the Department of Justice
because after all there were a bunch of
people who've lied to Congress in the
recent past there have been a lot of
people have lied to official government
sources in the recent past up to and
including Andrew McCabe who was fired
from the FBI for lying to the FBI
and yet Roger stone was the only one
who's looking at a decade in prison and
so the generalized perception is that
the reason that Roger stone was being
hit with this is specifically because he
was a ally of President Trump and
specifically because there are members
of the jury who were biased against
Roger stone and hated President Trump so
the real question here was did these
prosecutors recommend the correct
sentence had they run that up the
flagpole at the Department of Justice
had it been approved by the top levels
of the Department of Justice and then
had Trump stepped in to tell his own
attorney general I want you to lower the
sentence because there are two
possibilities here possibility number
one is that these DOJ lawyers who are on
this case did not in fact run this thing
up the flagpole they just decided to go
rogue because they wanted to humiliate
Trump they wanted to humiliate Barr and
they wanted to humiliate stone and they
recommended a sentence that was way too
long
specifically so that they could then set
up a walk out when the AG decided to
knock it down
that's possibility number one and that's
basically what's been suggested by the
Trump administration possibility number
two is the more nefarious possibility
and troubling possibility and that is
that the President of the United States
personally interfered after Barr had
already greenlit the sentencing
recommendation of Roger stone so CNN
reported that the rapid-fire
developments in the case the prosecutors
withdrawal came one by one through court
filings over the course of two hours on
Tuesday afternoon which certainly by the
way looks pretty coordinated right
generally if you were going to have like
a walkout like this I would assume
that's at least somewhat coordinated it
spilled tensions between Justice
Department brass and career prosecutors
out into the open raising questions
about the Justice Department's
independence from political pressure and
a new filing on Tuesday the US
Attorney's Office in Washington revised
the sentencing recommendation to be far
less than the 79 years recommended on
Monday it was not signed by any of the
prosecutors who worked the case
ultimately the presiding judge will have
the final say on Roger stones sentencing
Trump denied any involvement in the
sentencing revision but the turnaround
drew howls from congressional Democrats
they of course it suggested that the DOJ
Inspector General needed to investigate
now first of all it is not criminal
activity even if Trump interfered with
the DOJ because the DOJ is supposed to
have a certain level of Independence but
they do work for the presidents of the
United States the President does have
the right to interfere in policy this
way if you don't like it we have
elections for that sort of thing
obviously we've had cases in the past in
which the president has used his
constitutional power in very
questionable ways most obviously with
the mark rich pardon under Bill Clinton
which was sort of a similar
situation right political ally of
President Clinton and then non senator
but about to be senator Hillary Clinton
pardoned in the last days of the Clinton
administration and then a lot of howls
of protest
calls about corruption and all the rest
of the floor prosecutors withdrew from
the case
Aaron Solinsky Jonathan Kravitz Adam jet
and Mike mirando so lens gain Kravitz
also resigned from the DC US Attorney's
Office zalenski did not resign from the
Baltimore US Attorney's Office where he
is based which is kind of fascinating
you would figure that if he is so anti
the administration he would resign from
all of his federal offices he did not do
that the mass withdrawal was set in
motion on Monday when the prosecutors
from the DC US Attorney's Office who are
Justice Department employees wrote in a
filing that stone should be sentenced
seven to nine years in prison after he
was convicted on seven charges last year
they came out of the Muller
investigation including lying to
Congress and witness tampering and then
Trump waited on Twitter overnight on
Tuesday he called it a horrible and very
unfair situation and then he tweeted out
the real crimes were on the other side
as nothing happens to them cannot allow
this miscarriage of justice by midday
Tuesday a senior Justice Department
official said the original sentencing
recommendation from the prosecutors
transmitted to a judge and signed off on
by the officers top Prostate by the
offices top prosecutor had never been
communicated to leadership at the DOJ so
the official told CNN the department was
shocked to see the sentencing
recommendation the department believes
the recommendation is extreme and
excessive and is grossly
disproportionate to stones offensive so
the question was was that coming
courtesy of President Trump or was that
current coming courtesy of Attorney
General William Bar okay in just a
second we're going to get to William
Barr and we're gonna get to the reaction
to all of this we'll get to that
momentarily first let us talk about the
fact that you need to take advantage of
technology when you are shopping
otherwise you are simply missing out
there is seriously no reason why you
would not use the internet for all of
your shopping and this is particularly
true when you're talking about things
like home insurance very often home
insurance comes through word of mouth or
somebody tells you they have a good home
insurance policy oh I'll go check it out
you don't even bother to shop around cuz
it's really time-consuming it's a giant
pain in the butt here's the good news
policy genius com will take care of it
for you they'll get you all of the
competitive pricing all of the
information you need to make a solid
decision about your home insurance
policy genius com will compare your
policy against options from top insurers
and make sure you are getting the right
home insurance coverage at the best
possible price they've saved their
customers
average of six hundred and ninety
dollars per year doing just that if
policy genius finds you a better rate
than what you're currently paying that
will do all the work to get you switched
as well and if you own a car policy
genius will compare your home and auto
policies across different insurers and
even mix-and-match to find you savings
get home insurance at policy genius calm
in minutes you can get the ball rolling
on a policy for our new home or you can
reach op your current policy policy
genius they know you're always gonna get
the future wrong this is why you need to
get all of your insurance right go get
it done at policy genius calm again
that's policy genius.com there's some
other questions with regard to the Roger
stone case most obviously that the lead
juror in the Roger stone case ran for
Congress as a Democrat in 2012 and spent
the intervening several years
criticizing Trump and yes tweeting about
Roger stone which is a horrible job of
jury vetting I mean that that is really
not a great job of jury vetting by the
defense counsel in this particular case
with all of that said the question is
whether Trump himself interfered or
whether Barr had made a decision and
then Trump went public that was
congratulating bar on his decision which
again calls the the sort of quasi
independence of the DOJ and the question
makes it look like Barr as a political
hack who's just doing the bidding of
President Trump that's of course exactly
how the Democrats wished to make it look
so this is a giant stupid stepping on a
rake by the President of the United
States senator Tim Kaine Democrat of
Virginia he says this is how democracies
die because power was instructed by
President Trump to do XY and Z number
one Trump does in fact have the legal
power to do that but is it a bad look
yeah it's definitely a bad look here is
Tim Kaine the President believes he's
above the law this was a real concern
after the impeachment was over last week
that the president would view acquittal
as just a carte blanche he can do
anything that he wants anybody who was
just trying to do their job and not
fighting against the administration or
being in an appropriate but we're just
raising questions is now being mowed
down with the sickle of this president
who's out for revenge this is how
democracies die yes I do like this
unless people snap back and say that's
not what we want
okay so Tim Kaine again making the case
that the the Republicans have perverted
the Justice Department they've perverted
it as opposed to Eric Oh again every
Republican right now is screaming
screaming to the to the wind
Eric Holder Obama's wingman fast and
furious Loretta Lynch Muller
investigation Hillary Clinton tarmac
like the politicization of the Justice
of Janet Reno like the politicization of
the Justice Department has been ongoing
so for everybody to claim that bill Barr
is the first person to be hit with any
sort of political pressure obviously
that's untrue nonetheless you have Nancy
Pelosi out there saying this is clearly
an abuse of power it's an abuse of power
except that probably it wasn't again the
solution with President Trump honestly
the most common answer to President
Trump doing a wrong thing or a thing
that appears to be wrong is he did
something dumb but he didn't actually do
the thing the Democrats are accusing him
of this has been true in every situation
where Democrats have accused him of a
thing right every situation where
Democrats accused him of a thing it's
Trump has a big mouth is the answer not
Trump did this nefarious thing so
Democrats always treat Trump it's funny
Trump treats Trump is though he's
playing for DHS Democrats treat Trump as
though he's playing for DHS the truth is
that Trump is almost never playing 40
chess right Trump doesn't play chess he
plays checkers okay and checkers is good
enough that is not a rip on his
political skill set right that is not a
rip on his instincts but he suggests
that Trump is a nefarious ly
coordinating with the Russians as
opposed to what is obvious he's going
out in public and he is saying what he
would say as a caller to this show
Donnie from Queens it's perfectly
obvious that that's what Sutton that
Trump was doing right during the
campaign when Trump would go out in
probably Vladimir if you got the emails
release them was that Trump coordinating
with the Russians or was that Trump
being a big mouth which is what the man
does as I've suggested 1 million times
on this program and Counting president
Trump's epitaph is going to say Donald
from 45th President of the United States
he said a lot of stuff and everybody who
follows Trump knows this and if the
media were honest they would understand
this too and if Democrats were honest
they would understand this too and they
could criticize Trump for saying the
stuff that he says and they could say
it's bad practice they could say it's
bad for him they could but instead they
immediately jumped you the most
conspiratorial version of what Trump is
doing here which is that Trump told
William bar you need to step in in the
Roger stone case as opposed to William
Barr who is a career professional did
his job and then Trump proceeded to step
all over it like your dog having rolled
around in the mud and jumping on your
fresh carpet right here is Nancy Pelosi
suggesting this is an abuse of power is
that the abuse of power is just front
now thing off because it's always Trump
mouthing off like how many times do I
have to point out
then when Trump mouths off it rarely is
backed by any sort of plan
Trump is the Joker of American politics
but like from The Dark Knight there's no
plan no plan he's a dog chasing a car
sometimes he catches the car there's no
plan but according to his biggest
supporters there's always a plan
according to his biggest detractors
there's always a plan
hey politics is not house of cards guys
politics is veep politics is a joke
everybody who represents you is an idiot
and make this absolutely clear the
people you vote for are morons that are
the same morons you see in everyday life
working at your office except they
decided to go into politics which is
even more moronic because they're not
even producing anything useful for the
world this is true of everyone it's true
of virtually virtually everyone in all
aspects of life is an idiot
always always you know give people the
credit of assuming they're dumb not that
they are nefarious or evil because the
vast majority of the time they are in
fact dumb and not nefarious or evil and
even when they are nefarious or evil
half the time it's because they're dumb
in the first place
like I think the Bernie Sanders is a
dumb dumb I think he believes in
nefarious and/or evil things I think
it's because he's a
right I don't think the Bernie Sanders
is a highly intelligent human being
there are people on the Left who are
highly intelligent nationally planned
out what they're going to say and
they've thought through the theory and
then they come to exactly the wrong
conclusions because they have been
infused with the thought system that
that makes people worse but the notion
that like everybody in politics is
sitting around and planning things but
it's just not real but this is what
politicians have an interest in
suggesting the evil nefariousness of the
opposite party so here's Nancy Pelosi
suggesting that President Trump was
abusing power by tweeting crap which is
what he does on a daily basis this is by
the way this is why the American people
don't pay any attention to Nancy Pelosi
when she says this stuff it's why the
American people didn't pay attention
during impeachment because the American
people were like all right so like your
suggestion is that Trump coordinated an
entire nefarious scheme in order to get
Joe Biden in Ukraine utilizing Rudy
Giuliani alternatively Trump is
thin-skinned and says a lot of stuff and
says to people things like go get him go
get him Rudy which sounds more plausible
to you
hey here's Nancy Pelosi suggesting this
is an abuse of power this is an abuse of
power that the president is again trying
to manipulate federal law enforcement to
serve his political interest and the
president is what he is
he thinks he's above the law he has no
respect for the rule but where are the
Republicans to speak out on this blatant
violation the Attorney General has
stooped to such levels he's lied to
Congress for which he will be in
contempt he has engaged in these
activities what a sad disappointment to
our country okay so now this brings us
to attorney general bart finally
speaking out it's about time it's about
damn time seriously because I'll be
honest with you I know a lot of people
who work at the White House obviously I
mean like everybody in conservative
politics know somebody who works at the
White House I know lots of people who
work at the White House and a couple of
days ago on the podcast I suggested that
this looked really bad and some of my
friends at the White House like well did
you see the statement that a senior
official DOJ gave CNN saying that the
lower down goj officials did not run
this up the flagpole before it was
approved they just could have sort of
went out there with the sentencing and I
said to some of my friends who worked at
the White House like so why don't you
just say that clearly why do you not
send out Attorney General bar to say
very clearly that he was not manipulated
by President Trump here and that Trump
basically just decided to sound off like
Donnie from Queens calling into the show
about his opinion on this matter well
yesterday that's exactly what Attorney
General William bar did and good for him
good for him and by the way if you want
this is a great lip mist test if you
want to tell who in conservative circles
actually is being honest with you at
least some of the time and who in
conservative circles is being entirely
dishonest with you and it's just there
to act as a sicko fan tech press corps
for the president notice how they react
to Bar K bar is a is an excellent civil
servant he has done his job in my
opinion as Attorney General of the
United States I don't believe the
nefarious conspiracy theories about the
perversion of William bar or the or the
perversion of rod Rosen Stein I never
believed that stuff I never believed
about the perversion of Robert Malwa I
don't believe any of those things I
didn't like Robert Muller's report I
thought that it was politically
motivated at least in how it was worded
I thought that he exceeded his mandate
but I never thought that Robert Muller
was the bad guy a nefarious bad guy and
I don't think that William bar is a
nefarious bad guy everybody who one
second ago was saying William bar is the
greatest thing since sliced bread and
now that he has crossed the president
they're like trait or trait or
understand those are people who do not
have principles understand that doesn't
or not honestly analyzing politics
they're just giving you the rah-rah
Homer fanboy Trump case okay even and by
the way that case is not good for Trump
it's not good for Trump those fanboys
are doing no service to Trump because
all they are doing is incentivizing him
to continue saying stupid things that
undermine his own administration I'll
get to this in one second first let's
talk about the fact that you would never
ever ever use your internet without a
VPN why wouldn't you do that well for
the same reason we wouldn't leave the
bathroom door unlocked in a public place
right for the same reason you would
leave your car unlocked or your house
unlocked I think the fact is that if you
want privacy or security you should lock
the door well your internet your that's
your privacy that is your security all
right the fact is that your data is
yours alone and there are hackers who
want it there are people who want your
credit card number there are people who
are coming after your online information
so they can use it to monetize you well
you should stop all of this by using a
VPN I've been doing it for years you
should be using Express VPN did you know
that your internet service provider like
Comcast or Verizon knows every single
website that you visit what's worse they
can sell that information to ad
companies and tech giant's who use your
data to target you while expressvpn puts
a stop to this it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the Internet so your online activity
cannot be seen by anyone expressvpn
works on all of your devices phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your Wi-Fi can still be protected
even if they don't even have expressvpn
which is pretty awesome the best part is
using Express VPN is as easy as simply
closing and locking at the door so if
you're like me and you believe your
online activity is your business secure
that online activity visit expressvpn
comm slash Ben today use my exclusive
link expr ESS VPN comm slash Ben you can
get an extra three months for free
that's expressive VPN calm slash pen
today expressvpn calm slash pen okay so
finally we get to William bar so William
by the Attorney General he does an
interview with ABC last night and in
this interview he basically says to
president from shut up let's just stop
stop I'm doing my job here and here you
are sounding off and you're making it
sound as though you pressured me into
doing my job when in reality I'm just
doing my job
could you just shut up like seriously
just stop now a lot of Trump fans like
why would William Barr say this his
Twitter is the greatest thing that ever
happened to mankind and William Byers
like okay so you already undercut your
former attorney General Jeff Sessions
then you brought me in and I have not
recused myself from case
is the way the Jeff Sessions did and by
the way I defended Jeff Sessions like
Ben Shapiro
I personally defended Jeff Sessions I
think he's an honest man I think William
Barra is an honest man I think most of
the people who have worked around Trump
with the exceptions and people like
Michael Cohen are honest men okay so and
women
so William Barr he finally goes out on
ABC News's listen I'm doing my job and
it doesn't help when the president is
out there making it appear as though I'm
a corrupt Politico I will make those
decisions based on what I think is the
right thing to do and I'm not going to
be bullied or influenced by anybody and
I said if I'm whether it's Congress
newspaper editorial boards or the
president I'm gonna do what I think is
right I cannot do my job here at the
department with a constant background
commentary that that undercuts main
tweets made about the department about
people in the department are men and
women hear about cases pending in the
department and about judges before whom
we have cases make it impossible for me
to do my job of course that's a hundred
percent true 100 percent true and even
close allies of the president are coming
out and saying yes bar is correct Barra
is correct because you're undercutting
your own legitimacy as presidents of the
United States when you make it appear
that William bar is like Michael Cohen
that William bar is like Roy Cohn that
he's your fixer right that is a bad look
for the president it's and by the way
it's not even true bar isn't doing that
so Mitch McConnell the Senate Majority
the Senate Majority Leader he does this
too he backs bar he says this is
ridiculous like of course bar is correct
and of course Trump should stop tweeting
about this crap and everyone knows this
okay this is not a secret again for all
of those in the audience for big Trump
fans and think that it's mega mega
underwater upside down Hungry Hungry
Hippos whenever the president logs onto
Twitter from the bathroom or on top of
the golden toilet it's not true everyone
in the White House knows this this is
not a secret yeah I don't know who these
people are who treating president
Trump's Twitter feed as though it is
communica as though is filled with
communicati on the Kremlin as though
they're there decoding Kremlinology
okay president from tweet stuff that he
feels like tweeting sometimes that is a
good idea sometimes that is a very bad
idea this is a case where it was a very
bad idea here a Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell defending bill bar
correctly by the way there's been no one
who's
more of Donald Trump's agenda done than
this guy right here who is really
responsible like Trump nominates the
judges it's McConnell's job to ram him
through right president Trump has ideas
about mitigating the effects of
Obamacare it's Mitch McConnell who makes
that happen now President Trump has an
impeachment that goes to the Senate it's
Mitch McConnell who handles that thing
so there's been no more beneficial
politician in DC for Trump than Mitch
McConnell here's McConnell saying to
Trump dude just stop just stop please
stop the president made a great choice
when he picked Mill bar to be Attorney
General I think the president should
listen to his advice so you have problem
with the president's tweeting as well I
think that the Attorney General says
it's getting on the way of doing his job
maybe the president should listen to the
attorney Joe so do you think the tweet
about his opinion on the Roger stone
sentencing recommendations is
inappropriate politically the Attorney
General has said it's making it
difficult for him to do his job I think
the president ought to listen to the
Attorney General of course that's true
of course that's run politically
speaking the more the President Trump
appears to be interfering in the process
the more the Democrats are going to be
able to make the moral case as false as
it is that Trump is in fact a complete
departure from the institution of the
presidency that Trump is a tyrant that
Trump is corrupt like why would Trump
give material to the left like this I
don't understand and he doesn't
understand either because he doesn't
really think about what he's doing when
he's on the Twitter's all he would have
to do is put one person between him and
the enter button on Twitter that's it
all he would have to do is have one
person screen of sweets listen we all
know if you're on Twitter you know the
draw of just being able to fire
something off that gives you a momentary
sense of thrill and from obviously feels
that when he sounds water because that's
how Twitter is built it's literally
built to do that okay but that does not
mean as president that this is the best
way to do this now meanwhile you know
it's another bad luck is attacking a
former chief of staff look again the
best thing that the president can do
when it comes to his his chief of staff
when it comes to his Attorney General
would be to just accept that they do
what they do he's the President of the
United States he doesn't need to respond
to every single thing particularly
people he hired it's not a great look
when you hire somebody and then you dump
all over them which is now done so like
half of his cabinet we'll get to more of
this in a second okay but first let us
talk about why you need to keep your
education going even after you leave
school even after you get a job so the
marketplace is constantly moving and one
of the things are constantly going to
want to do
be upping your game in terms of your
credentials in terms of the amounts of
education yeah but don't want to spend a
fortune you don't want to go to to your
local your local major university spend
a fortune on extension school get a get
a masters and lesbian dance Theory no
what you want is a practical bachelor's
or master's degree program you can do
online and you can learn at your own
pace and you can study wherever you're
most comfortable learning and this is
what Ashford University provides Ashford
University six week-long courses allow
you to take one course at a time being
enrolled in one course at Ashford means
you are considered a full-time student
you don't have to have an SAT GRE a GMAT
or other standardized test scores and
Ashford is fully accredited by W ASC
senior college and university commission
so get on the road to earning your
degree and making your dream job a
reality get credentialed and the time
while you're still working a job right
enroll now go to Ashford comm etu slash
Ben that's Ashford comm sorry Ashford
edu slash Ben Ashford edu slash Ben's to
start your degree today Ashford etu
slash Ben keep that education going even
as yearning a living for your family and
go major in something useful Ashford edu
slash man Ashford edu slash then go
check them out right now okay so as I
say the president doesn't have to sound
off on everything immediately after the
AG rebukes him what Trump should do at
this point is go silent instead he has
started on Friday that he had a legal
right to intervene in federal criminal
cases because it is more important for
him to be right than it is for him to do
something smart apparently in a morning
tweet Trump quoted bar as saying the
president has never asked me to do
anything in a criminal case and then he
said he had so far chosen not to
interfere in a criminal case he says
this is not mean I do not have as
president the legal right to do so I do
but I have so far chosen not to
defeating the point mr. president
obviously you have the legal power to do
a thing the president has many legal
powers to do things that does not mean
they should be undercutting your
Attorney General who by the way is
defending you from charges of corruption
here that's what Attorney General Barr
is doing this is just dumb it's just I'm
sorry it's just stupid stop it just stop
it
and the reason you should stop it by the
way it's the Democratic race on the
other side it's a complete crap show
it's a crap fest even Bernie Sanders his
own supporters are now trying to back
him off of his socialism I'll get to
that in a minute
like that's how scared they are that
Trump is gonna win reelection as I have
said it day in and day out for months at
this point the person was
most likely to be Trump in an election
his Trump and when Trump goes off on
these tangents the American people don't
care about them it makes Trump appear
petit and makes him appear foolish it's
it's just it's it's a waste of time it
is stupid another example of this so
John Kelly the former chief of staff he
had he had done a an interview with the
Atlantic and he was described as
defending Alexandrov Inman for his
testimony against Trump saying he said
that Vinh men lieutenant colonel
Vanneman who is this guy who's working
inside the White House and who reported
the the he sort of was involved with the
whistleblower is probably the best
available information that he had
reported the contents of the Ukraine
call to this whistleblower who then
reported it up the chain Kelly said we
teach them don't follow any legal order
and if you've ever given one you'll
raise it to whoever gives it to you that
this is an illegal order and then tell
your boss so Trump fired back on Twitter
Thursday morning he said when I
terminated John Kelly which I couldn't
do fast enough he knew full well that he
was way over his head being chief of
staff just wasn't for him he came in
with a bang went out with whimper but
like so many X's he missed the action
and just can't keep his mouth shut which
he actually has military and legal
obligation to do his incredible wife
Karen I have a lot of respect for one's
pulled me aside and said strongly that
John respects you greatly when we are no
longer here he will only speak well of
you wrong okay no is this a purposeful
conversation that Trump is having here
they truly is a purposeful doesn't have
surrogates you just say like John Kelly
had a different perception of this issue
than everybody else impeachment is over
and VIN Minh got it wrong Ben Minh had
serious policy disagreements but when
you bring somebody in and they're the
person who is really sort of your main
outlet to the world this is true when
John Kelly was in the White House he was
reportedly the person who was deciding
who would see Trump and then from just
craps all over him and he did the same
thing with Bolton you make enough
enemies and you're just waiting to be
stabbed in the back it's just bad stupid
policy it really is and then the White
House wouldn't stop so a White House
spokesperson came out and contradicted
John Kelly said I was in the room she
says Stephanie Grisham I was in the room
with Trump when he backed Trump on
things he now criticizes so great let's
escalate the debate so we can turn this
into a week long story as opposed to
John Kelly sounds it off to the Atlantic
and no one cared and it's the the Trump
administration needs to start
understanding the so-called Streisand
effect the Streisand effect is named
after Barbara Streisand the famous
singer there's one there's a famous
story where Barbara Streisand
State in Santa Santa Barbara I believe
it was it was photographed in a book of
sort of long-range photographs of the
coast and she got mad cuz she didn't
want there to be public photographs of
her house and no one had seen this
photographic if you'd like four times
but she was made aware of it so she
actually filed the lawsuit against the
photographer and immediately that photo
had now been viewed millions of times so
everybody knew what her house looked
like you think anybody was deeply
worried about what john kelly had to say
months after he left the White House
seriously but now we're just gonna
elevate the issue and turn it into a
week long story like they have a gift
for for turning gold into a sow's ear
it's just like what is the point of this
here's Stephanie grace from going after
John Kelly I was disappointed obviously
especially I saw some of the comments
that he made and I was in the room with
him when he actually backed the
president on many of the things that
he's now saying you know weren't great
talking about the media especially I
have heard John Kelly say some things
about the media so I thought it was a
little disingenuous
it's interesting that he's starting to
poke his head out and speak a little bit
more just like John Bolton as we're
getting close to an election but I'll
just I'll just end it with I was
disappointed again there's no point to
any of this especially because the
Democrats are imploding they are in the
midst of a slow-motion implosion that is
delicious to watch I've been saying
really for years not months years that
all Trump has to do is point like Donald
Sutherland at the end of invasion of the
body snatchers at the Democrats and he
will win an election that's all he has
to do just this that's all he has to do
no one wants to vote for Bernie Sanders
it's like 25 percent of the population
that likes Bernie Sanders
no one wants Bernie Sanders to be
President Joe Biden is collapsing
absolutely collapsing I mean he like
like the people in the in the death
dream scene from Terminator 2 he is just
blowing away with the win I mean he is
finished the Democrats are falling apart
and instead we get stories about
Attorney General bar and John can't like
what is the point of this what could
possibly be the point you got the best
economy in the last 50 years why is that
not the only message coming out of the
White House and I keep saying this stuff
and I feel like it's going in one ear
and out the other for a lot of folks
especially because everyone agreed that
this was real that this was the real
strategy after the State of the Union
address everyone agreed that that Trump
wins 55
percent of the vote instead we don't get
that from for two weeks we get we get
Trump fighting with his own staff and or
undercutting his own Attorney General
who by the way is again attempting to
defend him just silliness silliness on
every level okay the second running gets
to the Democratic side of the race or
Democrats are now trying to define
Bernie as a not socialist so after
spending years allowing Bernie Sanders
to grab the mantle of the party as the
socialist candidate they are trying to
now claim that he is not a socialist and
that he won't be a socialist as
president good luck with this we'll get
to that in just one second first let us
talk about the auto parts that you need
so have you frequently or ever had a
situation where something is broken in
your car you got to go to the local auto
parts Shore a store but you go there and
they don't have the part you're looking
for or they have a generic part that
it's not perfect for your car and not
only that it is overpriced
you should be using the power of the
online interwebs this is why you need
Rock Auto calm the prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers why would you spend up
to twice as much for the same parts the
rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer rockauto.com has
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic or your daily driver get
everything you need in a few easy clicks
delivered directly to your door
rockauto.com is a family business it
serves Auto Parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck right Shapiro's in
there how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you get the best
auto parts why would you possibly go
down so that local auto parts arts gonna
charge you a fortune and wait in line
it's gonna be a pain in the butt instead
just order the stuff that comes in the
mail and it's great it's exactly what
you need because they've got a great
selection and the best prices Rock Auto
calm and right Shapiro's and their how
did you hear about us box okay in just
one second we're gonna get into the
Democratic side of the aisle which again
is just a complete mess it's a complete
mess and Bernie is dumping out all of
his Oppo on Michael Bloomberg I don't
know that it's gonna make a dent but the
Oppo is the authorial get to that in one
second first it is that glorious time of
the week when I give a shout out to a
daily wire subscriber today as you know
what johnson on twitter he has two
dreams one of which is about to be
realized in the pic noah is holding his
deleted beverage vessel and having a
cold snowy winters day in shorts and in
kansas city chiefs t-shirt while
lounging back on what appears to be a
plaque in front of his university the
caption reads my dream is to be feet
shirt on the Ben Shapiro show and for it
to go back to being 70 degrees like it
was two days ago
hashtag Mizzou hashtag left his tears
tumblr hashtag ben shapiro show well
today is your lucky day my friend
featured you are now go put on some
actual winter clothes before you catch
something also we the jews will try and
change the weather just for you so keep
a look out for your weather forecast
today thanks for the pic really
appreciate it also last week i told you
all about this new awesome podcast the
cold war what we saw over the weekend
the podcast was number one in history
podcast and number five on all of the
apple podcast i'm not the only one
saying it's great it really is really
good by the way stay tuned a little bit
later on in the show and i'll show you a
little brief interview with the guy who
does this particular podcast the entire
podcast is about as you would imagine
the cold war and all the big events from
the berlin airlift and the korean war to
the Cuban Missile Crisis in the space
race all of this tied together with a
with a solid moral through line about
the differences between freedom and
collectivism go check out the Cold War
right now at daily wired.com slash Cold
War start listening to the show daily
wire comm slash Cold War go check it out
also check out our daily wire app also
go get a membership because then you get
all sorts of special access to me to two
additional hours of this show every time
we have all sorts of goodies for you go
check out a member she makes a great
Valentine's Day gift by the way show
someone you love them by getting them
more politics go to daily wire.com and
get yourself a subscription or that
special someone you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so Bernie Sanders obviously the
Democratic frontrunner which means the
president Trump has a pretty clear road
right here right
president Trump is in pretty good shape
with regard to his opponent because even
Democrats like mainstream Democrats are
going this guy's a communist when I say
mainstream Democrats I mean James
Carville like the head of President
Clinton's war room so Bernie Sanders
slammed Carville because a few days ago
Carville was on MSNBC and then he didn't
interview with Sean ihling over at Fox
where he said are you guys crazy why are
you nominating a communist so so Bernie
Sanders then slammed James Carville they
fired back at James Carville and here is
what Bernie Sanders had to say on CNN
James in all due respect is a political
hack who said very terrible things what
he was working for Clinton against
Barack Obama I think he said some of the
same things look we are taking on the
establishment this is no secret to
anybody we are taking on Trump the
Republican establishment Carville and
the Democratic establishment okay so
he's terrible and he's he's a political
hack so Carville responds to Bernie in a
perfectly appropriate way right would
yeah you gotta love James Carville I
mean at least the dude is honest about
who he is
I mean really so James Carville
immediately tells Peter Hamby he says
last night on CNN
Bernie called me a political hack that's
exactly who the f I am I am a political
hack I'm not an ideologue I'm not a
purist
he thinks it's a pejorative I kind of
like it at least I'm not a communist I
mean the man has a point the man has a
point at least he is not a communist by
the way that should be Trump 2020
honest to god that should be a slogan
seriously it should be trumps would not
not Keep America great it should be it
should be Trump 2020 at least I'm not a
communist I swear the man won 60% of the
vote because Bernie can't even run away
from that label right Bernie has been
embracing that label his entire career
Trump 2020 at least I'm not a communist
it's pretty fantastic okay suggested by
James Carville right there and i'm i
agree agree by the way mainstream
players in the Democratic Party are
realizing this so the Nevada Q linaria
Union had basically issued a flyer
saying that Bernie Sanders is the
of the world well now they announced
they would not endorse a candidate ahead
of the state's Democratic presidential
caucuses they're considered an
organizing behemoth in democratic
politics they 60,000 hotel and casino
workers across Nevada under their
tutelage the decision came after months
of aggressive according from candidates
eager to win support of the politically
powerful group they said we're not going
to endorse any political candidate but
we're committed to people voting we're
gonna work really hard to defeat Trump
the decision came a day after the union
said it had been viciously attacked by
supporters of Bernie Sanders for a flyer
the group issued this week that was
critical of his proposed
medicare-for-all plan the Union strongly
opposes Medicare for all on Tuesday
night the Union distributed a
presidential scorecard to its members
the flyer said that Sanders would end
keulen era healthcare which led to what
union officials described as hundreds of
harassing phone calls and Twitter
attacks from alleged Sanders supporters
including personal threats to the heads
of the Union so everybody started vying
for their for their endorsement but the
keulen Airy union was like this they're
just the worst like that Sanders is the
worst yes we're endorsing no one but
also Bernie is absolutely the worst and
what you are starting to see now is even
Bernie's own surrogates basically going
out there and saying he doesn't really
mean it guys he doesn't really mean it
like he's not really a socialist like we
keep saying he's a socialist but he's
not really a socialist now meanwhile
Bernie keeps climbing in his surrogates
are claiming at the same time that he is
going to do all of these major
ridiculous trillion-dollar plans we
talked about it yesterday 100 trillion
dollars in new spending over the next
ten years according to Brian Reid all of
the Manhattan Institute he's going to do
all that through Budget Reconciliation
which is insane that he's going to do it
with 51 votes and reconciliation sure
sure he is Axios reports even with the
expanding power of the presidency
Sanders would need Congress to approve
the most ambitious ideas he's known for
that's unlikely to happen even under the
strongest election scenarios for House
and Senate Democrats in November says
Medicare for all the green news eel free
college and other Sanders proposals that
excite the Democratic base would likely
hit a log jam in the Senate even with
his plans to make expansive use of the
power of budget rules to push his ideas
through with a bare majority yeah but
now the Democrats are trying to soft
sell Bernie socialism so after years of
Bernie saying what distinguishes me from
the rest of the parts
he's put on my social was I think
capitalism is bad and then as I pointed
out many times before he's wanted to
have it both ways
on the one hand he will say things like
free markets lead to very rich people
and very poor people and we need less
free markets and then you'll say okay so
you're talking like actual communism now
you're talking state-owned state
ownership of the means of production
nope I mean Denmark in Norway like what
those are capitalist countries make no
but I'm a socialist I'm not the
capitalist says she's been redefining
the word socialist I mean whatever he
wants it to mean for a while now
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez who is it she
was a member of the Democratic
socialists of America right all profit
margin is bad the free markets are
terrible now AOC is explicitly going out
there and downplaying the possibility of
Sanders ever effectuating his own agenda
so the promise is that a socialist is
different from everybody else because
he's going to make revolutionary change
well doesn't this undercut the
authenticity of the appeal if the idea
is that you're a revolutionary and then
in the backroom you're like I'm not
really a revolutionary I'm basically
like Hillary Clinton just less hair and
technically a man really good that
that's not quite the same page so AOC
AOC she argued that the realities of
governing or an actual argument for
someone like Sanders she said the worst
case scenario we compromise deeply and
we end up getting a public option is
that a nightmare I don't think so
so Bernie wants to outlaw private
insurance and aoc is basically saying
well as long as we get some moderate
changer so she's now advocating for PG
judge's plan or Amy Klobuchar planner
Joe Biden's plan while bernie is
maintaining that those plans are
insufficient and wrong which means that
someone is dishonest and Morrissey over
at hot air correctly says for someone
who's selling the revolution on the
stump for Sanders this sounds like a
mighty big retreat by aoc on the central
plank in his platform almost certainly
an unauthorized walk back
Sanders has other issues in his platform
but medicare-for-all is central to his
agenda his economic policies don't work
without it well they don't work at all
actually but especially not without a
complete switch to socialized medicine
furthermore Sanders has had plenty of
opportunities to offer compromises like
butta judges Medicare for all who want
it Sanders has steadfastly refused to
water down his vision by a single inch
don't be so sure that Sanders agrees
with though cause record says he can't
get his agenda through Congress either
but the fact that aoc is walking it back
and it's not just a Oh see I poked
Krugman is doing the
thing so Krugman over at the New York
Times he says that Republicans are
constantly calling things socialist that
aren't socialist but then he says the
thing is Bernie Sanders isn't actually a
socialist in any normal sense of the
term oh really oh really well welcome to
the real world Democrats who have been
claiming that socialism is dead listen
to this he doesn't want to nationalize
our major industries and replace markets
with central planning has expressed
admiration not for Venezuela but for
Denmark he's basically what Europeans
would call a social democrat and social
democracies like Denmark are in fact
quite a nice place to swivel with
societies that are if anything freer
than our own who's been saying this for
years
who can I think of someone who's been
saying for years the Denmark Norway that
these are not socialist countries there
these are capitalist countries with
heavy social welfare systems and Bernie
is dishonest to call himself a socialist
while constantly stumping for policies
then in many case some more
business-friendly
than the policies of the United States
who's been saying that for years who
gave a speech on this like I think it's
a Georgetown like maybe three years ago
who's been saying this for years and
then we got nothing though socialism
really is Denmark in Norway he's a
socialist
those are socialist countries socialism
is dope okay so now that the election
approaches now you're going to
acknowledge the Bernie isn't actually a
socialist yeah I know I know
or are you just going to acknowledge
that Bernie is in fact a socialist in he
wants to nationalize things because
here's the dirty little secret about
Krugman Bernie's split the baby the
whole way Bernie's never come out
against nationalization he has never
come out against municipal izing
industry but he doesn't
Krugman I think is right here he says
why does Sanders call himself a
socialist I say it's it's mainly about
personal branding with a dash of glee at
shocking the bourgeois the
self-indulgence did no harm as long as
he was just a senator from a very
liberal state but if Sanders becomes the
Democratic presidential nominee his
misleading self description will be a
gift to the Trump campaign okay so
basically now you have Sanders trapped
between a rock and a hard place on the
one hand socialism is deeply unpopular
but socialism is also the only branding
separation between Bernie and Biden
really like the policies of Biden are
not that far removed from policies of
burning when people talk about a
moderate lane in the Democratic Party
they are talking about the difference
between Trotsky and Lenin
okay these are there is no actual
moderate Lane in the Democratic Party
Biden and Budaj are not far separated in
policy from Bernie Sanders it's just the
burning wants it immediately and Biden
and Buddha judge said they want to
gradually at the different
between elizabeth warren's ii plan which
was gradually go to medicare-for-all and
her first plan which was immediate
medicare for almost three years
biden by the way is not in favor Biden
says he's not in favor of Medicare for
all but as a first step do you think
Biden's in favor of a public option that
morphs into Medicare for all you bet
your ass he is within five years by
it'll be something for Medicare for all
within six months if Bernie Sanders is
the nominee hey so that so the fact is
that the separation between the Bernie
wing of the party and the rest of the
party is not obvious and never was
obvious so Bernie had to separate
himself off by calling him a socialist
himself a socialist but the problem is
if you do that Americans don't like
socialism because at least they're not
communist and so now he's having to
revise that and now he's having to say
oh by the way when I say socialism I'm
not actually a socialist oh really okay
okay so Democrats are trapped with this
crap nominee when this really bad
nominee and meanwhile Joe Biden who has
high name recognition is well liked in
the black community has had until the
last five minutes high approval ratings
has completely fallen apart in the
middle of this race james Clyburn
represented from south carolina he says
listen if by the lose South Carolina is
basically his last stand Abidin loses
South Carolina he's toast
what happens if Joe Biden does not win
South Carolina he will be in a very
precarious situation he needs to win
South Carolina to demonstrate that his
philosophy about the campaign is correct
that is right that is right if Joe Biden
loses South Carolina he is done but
Biden is also correct when Biden says
the Democrats don't want to campaign
with a socialist a Biden's points about
Sanders are exactly true I think the
next president always to beat Trump they
have to bring along a Democratic Senate
and I think you look I went out in the
24 states for 66 candidates they're all
the frontline candidates are in purple
states and red states we won back the
house we increased governorships and
best of my knowledge I don't think
anybody asked Bernie to come in and
campaign there maybe this is exactly
right Bernie doesn't have it Democrats
are freaking out and they should be
freaking out so who shall they turn to
who shall they turn to was Biden fades
people are increasingly turning to
Michael bloomer
which means that Biden is now turning on
Michael Bloomberg he says he wants to
debate Michael Bloomberg he wants to hit
him on redlining and stop and frisk
there's only one problem
this is idiocy the reason that this is
idiocy is because number one Biden was
the guy behind the 1994 criminal
criminal justice bill so he was one of
the people behind it which was part of
the same movement that was behind things
like stop and frisk generally and
Biden's own history working with people
who were in favor of actual segregation
obviously has come back to bite him once
in the campaign but beyond that what is
the strategy here for Joe Biden you take
out Michael Bloomberg in which state
exactly in which state because it's
either make or break for Joe Biden in
South Carolina if Joe Biden loses South
Carolina he's out of the race he's toast
if he loses South Carolina to Bernie
Sanders he's finished and that means he
has to drop out well Bloomberg isn't
technically even in the race yet
Bloomberg doesn't get into the race
until the following week look at the
calendar
Bloomberg is not on any ballots until
after South Carolina so if Biden were to
fall in South Carolina and he's
simultaneously hurt Michael Bloomberg in
this debate how has that benefited the
so-called moderate wing of the party
that opposes Bernie Sanders instead he's
knocked down the guy who's spending 300
million dollars and rising in national
polls and now according to one poll
leading in Florida leading in Florida
Michael Bloomberg so this is I mean what
Joe Biden is doing by going after
Michael Bloomberg is basically the same
thing that chris Christie did to Marco
Rubio in New Hampshire in 2016 it's a
murder-suicide it's a political
murder-suicide he's trying to take out
Michael Bloomberg in advance of
presumably him losing South Carolina
followed by Michael Bloomberg being hit
on all of the things that Joe Biden is
bringing up so here is Joe Biden for
some reason believing that his chief
rival to the nomination is Michael
Bloomberg as opposed to Bernie Sanders
which again that's putting an awful lot
of stock in South Carolina like if Biden
had any if if Biden had any wherewithal
at all he would get out of the race the
chances that he's gonna win I think I
think he's a heavy I think he's a heavy
loser in South Carolina I'd be shocked
if he went South Carolina here is Joe
Biden going after Bloomberg nonetheless
one of the advantages and disadvantages
I've been the only guy through this
process so far a person has been totally
vetted I mean I've been I've had a
target on my back since I got in I'm
standing and I'm gonna get a chance to
debate
Mayor Bloomberg a chance to debate him
on everything from redlining to stop and
frisk to a whole range of other things
so he's gonna go after Bloomberg again
what is the strategy here this is the
big problem for the Democrats if they
don't mobilize their their moderate
their so-called moderate wing that
doesn't really exist if they don't
mobilize that so-called moderate wing
then Bernie's gonna take the nomination
so instead you've got Joe Biden who is
strategically inept going after Michael
Bloomberg again if he wants to win South
Carolina hitting Michael Bloomberg isn't
gonna help him one iota seriously if his
strategy is to win South Carolina he
needs to knock down Bernie he doesn't
need to knock down Bloomberg how the
hell does it help him to hit Bloomberg
when we're getting on the ballot in
South Carolina it's it's massive massive
idiocy meanwhile Bernie Sanders is
dropping every piece of Apple he can on
Michael Bloomberg there are there's only
one problem some of the oppo on Michael
Bloomberg actually cuts in favor of his
ability to win in the middle of the
country the fact that Michael Bloomberg
was tough on crime is not a bad pitch to
people who are living outside of New
York my the way it wasn't a bad pitch
for people living inside New York City
the man was a three-term mayor of New
York City so the this is all amazing to
watch this is why I say president Trump
stop with the Twitter just point just
keep retweeting James Carville and again
take his suggestion Trump 2020 at least
I'm not a communist pretty fantastically
fantastically good slogan okay time for
a quick thing I like and then we'll get
to a quick thing that I hate so things
that I like today I promised you earlier
on in the program that I was going to
play you a bit of an interview that I
did a little bit earlier with Bill
Whittle bill is the host of the Cold War
a brand-new podcast that we have been
working on here at Daily wire one to
number one in history on the Apple
podcast went to number five overall it
really is fantastic it's great listening
it's dramatic I sat down with Bill we
talked about the Cold War we talked
about the implications for the Cold War
in today's politics particularly since
we apparently are going to nominate an
emissary of the USSR for the Democratic
Party we're joined on set by Bill
Whittle though of course as an author
public speaker and he's provided
political commentary for Fox News
National Review among other things he's
also the writer and performer of Apollo
11 what we saw the podcaster is which
went to number one on iTunes and his
back with season two the cold war what
we saw which couldn't be more relevant
today bill thanks for stopping by great
to be here Ben so let's talk about the
Cold War what we saw what what is the
actual scope of the series what's it
about well it's a
two year piece of history and that's a
lot of history and I wanted to tell the
story from the point of view that I've
never heard it told about before people
talk about the conflict and there's the
economic and the the military and all
the rest of it but I wanted specifically
to concentrate on the moral aspects the
moral differences between these two
sides because the way it's taught retro
actively its kind of oh it's Coke versus
Pepsi and a team blue team red
more or less the same begun
misunderstanding - giant militaristic
countries with these armies and and
missiles and they're more or less the
same but they're not they're not more or
less the same what I basically did was I
decided with all of the terms that have
changed so much liberals conservatives
Hawks and and so on
it's individualist versus collectivist
that's the Cold War right there
it's it's a collectivist ideology that's
been here from the beginning of time
namely that the peasants are just
dispensable pieces of people that you
throw into the machine versus this
brand-new ideology of individualism and
and when the Cold War started this
collectivist idea just kind of limped
and then started to run from the east
from from Stalingrad and then this
individualist philosophy came ashore at
Normandy and where they met at the end
of World War two was what began the
stage for World War three so with all of
that said we're seeing the the Cold War
obviously has great echoes today in the
United States moon when the Soviet Union
fell there was a widespread perception
that communism had been defeated right
and now we see Bernie Sanders who back
literally every communist regime of the
20th century you know so long as he has
been alive and he is in all likelihood
going to be the Democratic nominee so
what exactly has happened that Americans
forgot about the moral conflicts in
which by the way the Democratic Party
was on the right side of this during the
Co absolutely yeah yeah Truman and
Kennedy and and yeah Bernie Sanders took
his honeymoon you know if you really
want to go someplace with your beloved
someplace where you can relax kind of
kick back what better than Moscow in
early spring right there's video of
Bernie in a room with other Russians and
he's singing this land is your land this
land is my land Bernie Sanders must know
that well Bernie Sanders supporters we
saw on tape some vist campaign
organizers talking about how swelled the
gulag was and how swell the the the
white sea canal is the worst of the
places in the gulag was it was a camp
called Colima
where the temperature in the winter
coincidentally is the only place where
Fahrenheit and centigrade match it's 40
degrees below zero and Bernie's position
would be well it wasn't a death camp
like the Nazis it was a work camp it was
a work camp and your life expectancy was
about a year and if you lived it if you
were working in the gold mines it was
four months we think that probably
800,000 people maybe a few more died in
Colima that's one camp in the entire 300
plus camps of the gulag that means that
coal amount on the leader board from
hell is probably third now it's first
Treblinka second column a third terms of
number of people who've been murdered in
one particular patch of land Bernie
Sanders goes over to this place and
sings this land is your land this land
is my land one of the guys who was in
his campaign said socialism well first
of all after he talked about putting my
political opponents in the gulags which
he then went on to defend he also said
and they had they've got together and
built this canal the people got together
and just built a canal well King Richard
goda who was head of the secret police
had attempted to impress Stalin by
building a canal from the from the
Baltic to the white sea and he used 125
prison 125,000 laborers from the
prison's 25,000 of them were killed on
the job
that's a hundred and seventy seven
individual human lives per mile and when
the canal was finished it was built so
quickly that they couldn't put any ships
through it and this is what Bernie's
campaign people and Bernie himself think
of as the model society the reason we're
even talking about having a socialist
today is because we have never had a
consistent ongoing this
pointing out point by point of how many
people have to die to make this thing
work and the final final final thing is
this Fidel Castro is a man of the people
as a Soviet you know he's a he was oh he
was a man of the people when he had died
had 800 million dollars in his personal
bank account Lenin didn't go back to
being a failed lawyer Trotsky didn't do
this and and Bernie Sanders who's
talking about income inequality has
three house
I mean well bill Whittle the series is
the Cold War what we saw as you can tell
bill is an expert in American history
and in world history his last podcast
Apollo 11 what we saw is fantastic if
you haven't listened to that you should
and make sure you tune in for the Cold
War what we saw I'm sure it's going to
be brilliant and well produced as always
I know because we helped produce some of
it so go check it out right now the Cold
War what we saw bill thanks so much for
stopping by good it's like pleasure Ben
it's always great to be here so I agree
with me obviously go check out the Cold
War daily wire.com slash Cold War
already time for a quick thing that I
hate so there's a person named Dana
Schwartz an American and journalist and
author who was previously a
correspondent to Entertainment Weekly
yesterday she was trending on Twitter
why well cuz she was attacking South
Park South Park is bad South Park is
canceled South Park is mean and cruel
and bad and cancelled she tweeted out in
retrospect it seems impossible to
overstate the cultural damage done by
South Park the show that portrayed
earnestness as the only sin and taught
that mockery is the ultimate inoculation
against all criticism couple notes on
this it is extraordinary continues that
smugness is not the same as intelligence
provocation isn't the same as bravery
the lesser of two evils aren't the same
so I generally agree with the principle
that mockery is not a substitute for
actual values but I'm not gonna hear
that from a bunch of people on the Left
who worship that the altar of Jon
Stewart Jon Stewart spent years just
making smug faces at cameras with a live
audience
by the way Jon Stewart's show was so
reliant on the live audience that if you
actually removed the live audience his
show would lose all the laughs it's like
it's like it's sitcom from the 1980s you
remove the laugh track and it just aint
funny anymore
and Jon Stewart was heavily dependent on
that live audience but the fact is that
smugness and mockery have been the
hallmark of the comedy central left for
a very long time in South Park was on
Comedy Central - the real problem the
Danish Wars has is she doesn't like the
people that South Park attacks she
doesn't like the fact that South Park
attacks attacks quote unquote victims
according to the left now what South
Park has really done is it's focused in
on the insufferable the insufferable
smugness of the left so it's not smug
about about people on the left with
values it's smug about people on the
Left who are who are cynically
attempting to use faux values in order
to cram down a particular version of
society right the
the most famous sort of image from South
Park along these lines is a bunch of San
Francisco liberals smelling their own
farts right that's that sort of the
South Park message okay but that is the
reality of the situation trying to rip
on South Park is sort of a sign of
Western civilization's decline is pretty
amazing again if you want to make the
case that that South Park is crude and
rude and lewd all of that is true but I
don't remember the left ever objecting
to crude rude and lewd so long as it was
siding with them what they don't like
about South Park the reason they're
angry about South Park is because South
Park dares to speak some truths about
politically correct stupidity and
therefore it is bad and therefore it is
canceled so by the way South Park is I
never watched it as a kid because it was
too lewd rude and crude for me as an
adult I've watched some episodes it's
quite brilliant I mean it for adults
it's really funny the the writing on it
is hysterically hysterically funny
because Matt Stone and Trey Parker are
actually extremely talented people much
more talented than any of the comedy
writers who ever worked for Jon Stewart
meanwhile quick update on coronavirus
just to make your weekend brighter I
feel like we should do an update on
coronavirus so China has now announced
5,000 new cases in 121 new deaths it's
really fun to watch as the Chinese
government stifles all information about
coronavirus and then immediately
suggests that they are being transparent
with the people of Earth and that
everything is under control they've
basically turned into they've turned
into Kevin Bacon in Animal House
shouting that everything is under
control while they're raw you know
running after people in the streets
tackling them and dragging them away
it's pretty astonishing stuff the the
latest from China is that they're
coronavirus outbreaks showed no signs of
peaking with health authorities on
Friday reporting more than 5,000 new
cases while passengers on a cruise ship
blocked from five countries due to virus
viewers finally disembarked in Cambodia
which is a great place to disembark
policymakers pledged to do more to
stimulate Asian economies hit hard by
the virus helping Asia stock markets
edged higher with Chinese shares headed
for their first weekly gain and for this
is really slowing the economy I know
people who do business in Hong Kong and
they've just stopped doing business in
Hong Kong basically because of all of
the fears about all of this the new
figures gave no indication the outbreak
is nearing a peak according to Adam
Conrad Scott and infectious diseases
expert at the Center for International
Security Studies at the University of
Sydney meanwhile the United States CDC
is
they're trying to keep this thing under
control the problem of course is that
the thing is basically silent until you
obtain it so it's silent even when it
comes to transmission when it comes to
transfer for a full on two weeks
everybody is is incredibly it like the
symptoms don't actually have to be
symptomatic to transmit the disease in
other words which means that it is very
very difficult to get people to sign on
to get people to to get people to you
know limit this thing so limit the
transmission of this thing so this the
good news is that China has this under
control
China's Hubei and Wuhan Communist Party
Chiefs are removed amid the epidemic so
they blew the whole thing because the
government insisted on top-down control
and then they are presumably gonna be
sent to some sort of labor camp for
having tried to shield the party from
the blowback from coronavirus the same
thing by the way has happened to many of
the doctors who were trying to document
this stuff according to D and y uz com
the beige man squatted outside of a
Wuhan hospital its side and back doors
ajar Fang been a local clothing salesman
peered inside as he walked past he grown
so many dead he counted five six seven
eight body bags this is too many that
moment in a 40-minute video about the
corona virus outbreak that has
devastated China propelled mr. Fang to
internet fame then less than two weeks
later he disappeared China great place
to be when you're not dying of
coronavirus they are arresting you for
announcing the corona virus actually
exists so exciting stuff as always from
our friends in the evil Chinese
communist government truly truly evil
okay now quick note since it isn't
Friday I haven't done a Bible thing in a
little while so let me do a quick Bible
study segment with you right now I know
running a Louisville wait it's okay it's
okay we're going to end the week on an
up note so this week's Torah portion for
the Jews is the is the portion that
contains the Ten Commandments the parsha
of each row which is kind of fascinating
because the partial with the Ten
Commandments is actually named after a
non Jew right you throw is the
father-in-law of Moses and was
considered sort of the high priest of
Midian and he supposedly he kind of
supposedly according to various
commentaries converts to Judaism after
the splitting of the Red Sea he
approaches Moses he explains to him how
a hierarchical judicial system should
work with a court of appeals with Moses
sitting at the top and all this in the
parsha is named after him which is a
suggestion as to some of the interesting
things about the Ten
okay so the Ten Commandments obviously
the most important statement of morality
probably in the hit most impactful in
the history of humanity and there's
always been this interesting sort of
tension between how much of the Ten
Commandments is discernible by human
reason and how much of the Ten
Commandments needed to be handed down by
the by by God how much of it needed to
be handed down as revelation there's
even some interesting commentary in in
Jewish sources as to whether God
actually announced all Ten Commandments
or whether he only and so in the in the
Torah God only announced the first two
commandments then the people say okay we
can't handle this God is too much for us
we need Moses to tell us the rest of
these things so Maimonides and in guide
to the perplexed if eclis talks about
what exactly it was that people were
were given at Sinai in terms of the Ten
Commandments from God directly right
because this is the the time in Jewish
history when God speaks directly to the
people as a corporate entity right it's
six hundred thousand Jews supposedly
standing in front of Mount Sinai so what
exactly did God do so apparently God was
so awesome according Maimonides that
people immediately intuited there is a
God and I shan't have had any other gods
before him so the first two Commandments
were even understandable simply from the
mere presence of God the mere power of
standing in front of God so how much of
the Ten Commandments is discernible from
natural law and how much of the Ten
Commandments is something that has to be
handed down and inculcated and taught
how much could we just sort of discover
on our own well the first two right the
first two Commandments I'm the Lord your
God who brought you out of the land of
Egypt out of the land of bondage right
that that basic concept is of course
something that has to be handed down
from God because you can logic your way
to the idea of a creator of the universe
but that logic doesn't necessarily carry
over into a God of history who cares
about you every single day who cares
about what happens to you and so God's
involvement with the world is a core
assumption that the Ten Commandments
makes and then hands down to you and
then you can discern some of the other
of the Ten Commandments from that right
like the obligation not to murder would
be a pretty obvious one because if every
human being is made in the image of God
which is in Genesis and God is is a God
who cares about individual human beings
and cares about history then you can
certainly Intuit the idea that you're
not supposed to kill or kidnap or steal
from other people right the basic idea
that you have an individual right
against other individuals that sort of
stuff does spring from the Ten
Commandment but there are certain
aspects of the Ten Commandments
that are I think necessary to be given
that are necessary to be given so some
of those for example the Sabbath
necessary to be given right there's
nothing that suggests that we shouldn't
be working all seven days per week but
what that really is in essence is a
recognition that we are in control of
our own time then we are not to be
slaves to the collective in the end the
ten commandments which are given
collectively to the Jewish people
corporately right that the Ten
Commandments are a ringing endorsement
of individual rights because when you
look at the Ten Commandments they're
nearly all about individual rights that
you have against other human beings at
first you have to acknowledge God second
you have to acknowledge that nothing
else can supplant God right government
cannot take over for God that is the DAO
shalt have no other gods before me
government can't take the role of God
government can't fix all cosmic in
Justices that is not the role of any
collective to do and any collective that
attempts to do so violates the first
commandment and the second commandment
and then there's the third commandment
that you shall take the name of the Lord
your God in vain which really is a
specific demand not to pervert the words
of Scripture my friends and as Prager is
I think it's a really great take on this
he says does God really care if you say
Gd
does God really care if you say a bad
curse word that has God's name in it he
says well you know probably shouldn't do
it but does is that really what the
commandment is about isn't really about
cursing and the answer is no the answer
is it the way you really shouldn't do is
supplant your own agenda for God's and
then call it God's I got to be very
careful about what you're doing people
who judge by trying to trying to suggest
that the Bible backs your particular
vision of the world in contravention of
God's explicit Word is a is an attempt
to take God's name in vain the fourth
commandment remember the Sabbath to keep
it holy
is again a statement of your
individuality and your individual right
to your own time
that the Sabbath is between you and God
but it's nobody else can force you to
work on the Sabbath that you got to have
breaks right you're in a slavery is
about other people being in control of
your time so the fourth commandment
which is the Sabbath the idea there is
that you are now in control of your own
time honoring your father and mother
right this is about understanding that
your rights and duties are handed down
parentally not from a society that
starts anew every single generation and
this is a real conflict in left and
right the left in the United States
believes that every single generation we
have to remake our morality as brand new
and reject the immorality of our parents
honoring your father and mother now
that you have a duty to examine the past
and you have a duty to examine your
forefathers because your rights come in
the words of Edmund Burke not just from
these kind of new version of
enlightenment rights but also handed
down via history the sixth commandment
you shouldn't murder obvious that
Springs from natural rights you
shouldn't commit adultery that Springs
from natural rights because you are
violating the the sanctity of an oath
that you took to another human being
when you commit adultery contra the New
York Times which by the way has an
article this week about sexually open
marriages again it's amazing I don't
know how repress they are at the New
York Times but like every other day
there's an article the New York Times
about how you should be able to cheat on
your spouse and your spouse should be
okay with it like a plea for a plea for
something from the editors of the New
York Times the 8th commandment you
shouldn't steal obviously an
acknowledgement of individual rights
right because if you haven't right to
something people don't have a right to
steal it from you the 9th commandment
they shouldn't bear false witness
against your neighbor again an
indication of individual rights and this
does come up fairly regularly right
people who suggest that due process does
not apply based on your social group
those people are violating your
individual rights they're bearing false
witness against neighbors based
specifically on their social
distinctions and finally you shouldn't
covet that is the greatest indicator in
favor of individual rights because you
don't have a right to somebody else's
property
or somebody else's life you can hope to
have a life as good as theirs but you
certainly do not get to covet other
people's property which is the basis of
the Bernie Sanders campaign and the
socialist left okay so the ten
commandments I think largely discernible
from the basic idea that God is presence
in the universe cares about you and
believes in you as an individual the
single most important statement of
morality presumably in human history the
most impactful certainly so go check it
out this week since it is that week in
the Jewish calendar and we will see you
here a little bit later today or barring
that we will see here next week with all
of the latest as we approach the Nevada
caucuses you're listening to the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
light house key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by micro Romina hair and makeup is by
NECA geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 25 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]